[Music]
if you love Payton list as much as we do
you're probably super excited to watch
her latest movie anthem of a teenage
prophet watch until the end to find out
which dark secrets list has been hiding
from the public's view number one will
leave you speechless
new around here don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's rummage
through the dark secrets surrounding
Peyton lists and her newest film she's
got a twin brother
Peyton list has a very impressive acting
background but do you know who else does
her twin brother Spencer list finding
out that one of your favorite actors has
a twin is always surprising especially
when they tend to keep their fame and
home life separate while some might say
that Payton is an open book she is
somewhat private when it comes to her
personal life the twins were born in
Florida where they quickly introduced
themselves to the world of show business
in fact both Payton and Spencer landed
their first roles before the age of four
and haven't stopped chasing the camera
since while they don't usually work
together the twins did act side by side
when they were six years old back then
Payton and Spencer were used as extras
on the set of spider-man 2 but that's
about as far as their collaborations go
oh and in case you're wondering Payton
is actually 10 minutes older than
Spencer and she never lets him forget it
while it's common for twins to connect
in bizarre ways Payton has stated that
she and Spencer hardly ever have strange
twin moments well unless you count
needing to go to the bathroom at the
same time she's good friends with Bella
Thorne Payton list has been in the
spotlight since she was a young girl so
it's not too surprising to find out that
she's close friends with many Disney
Channel actors after all the Disney
World is exceptionally intertwined while
some people are quick to judge bella
thorne for her fashion sense attitude
and way of life Payton can't say a bad
thing about her after all they have
known each other since they were
toddlers when it comes to these two
ladies though their relationship goes
beyond Disney did you know that Payton
and Bella were both born in Florida but
they began modeling together at the age
of four since both of these actresses
have chosen to evolve from the Disney
Channel their schedules are currently
packed with countless projects
regardless of this Peyton Bella have a
bond that can never be broken these
childhood friends are always happy for
one another whenever they land the big
time roll and they're quick to give each
other a shout-out on Twitter these
celebs might be very different but that
doesn't mean that they don't have common
ground
are you surprised to find out that these
two ladies go way back actually will not
be hard but you're above average penis
guarantees we'll get caught she has
terrible eyesight poor eyesight is an
issue that plagues more than 50% of the
population luckily there are plenty of
eye contact lenses and glasses to go
around
he might have noticed that Peyton lists
is often photographed wearing her large
black frames
however she isn't always allowed to wear
glasses on set since it all depends on
whether or not her character wears
glasses Peyton makes it a point to have
a pair of contact lenses on her at all
times but as many people have come to
find wearing glasses and makeup at the
same time isn't exactly ideal since
Peyton loves doing her makeup she
usually is scene without chunky frames
when going to a more prestigious event
it took Peyton's mother a long time to
realize that her daughter needed specs
but reality came rushing and when Kayden
was in fourth grade during a basketball
game Peyton's mother realized that her
daughter kept passing it to the wrong
team by accident and so she immediately
brought her to an optometrist after
being fitted for glasses the actresses
entire world changed for the better did
you know that Peyton didn't smile until
she was three years old well this might
have everything to do with the fact that
she could barely make out the shapes in
front of her despite her terrible
eyesight Peyton could clearly see that
anthem of a teenage prophet was going to
be an excellent movie anthem of a
teenage prophet is a low-budget indie
movie if you love drama and suspense
you're in for a real treat anthem of a
teenage prophet is a Canadian film that
is being showcased during the Vancouver
International Film Festival on October 6
2018 this anticipated movie will surely
blow as fewer socks off and why wouldn't
it after all it does revolve around the
teenage psychic who's been nicknamed the
prophet of death the movie is directed
by Robin Hayes and stars a high number
of up-and-coming actor
Cameron Monaghan and Peyton lists are
the leads and their chemistry is
undeniable the movie was filmed in
Vancouver under the sepia film
production company and while its content
is rich the movie doesn't have a huge
budget for this reason actors and crew
members were flown out to British
Columbia to complete the movie's hectic
filming schedule the project was
promptly filmed to save on expenses
which is why actors were made to share a
trailer regardless of this there isn't a
doubt in our minds that the
cinematographer Todd Dhoom pieced
everything together to make it look like
an expensive film Canada has long since
become a popular filming destination due
to their sites being more affordable
than American venues with this in mind
it isn't surprising to hear that many
small budget movies are being filmed in
Vancouver who is Peyton lists boyfriend
Peyton list is a 20 year old actress who
has a lot of credits under her name she
rose to fame in 2011 when she was cast
as Emma Ross in the hit Disney Channel
series Jessie since then she's landed
roles in movies like the swap and the
outcasts the young star has also been
featured in popular sitcoms like bunk D
and KC undercover and light as a feather
when it comes to her dating record some
might say that Peyton is a long-term
relationship gal due to her busy
lifestyle Peyton tends to pay little
mind to potential love interests however
she did meet her ex-boyfriend on the set
of Jessie
Peyton an ex co-star Cameron voice are
said to have dated for a total of three
years however their relationship ended
in mid 2015 since then Payton has solely
focused on her acting career which soon
brought her into the arms of a new
Cameron Peyton is currently dating her
anthem of a teenage profit co-star
Cameron Monaghan and she couldn't be
happier the couple made their
relationship official in July of 2017
and from where we're standing they are a
match made in heaven
Peyton likes to keep her personal life
to herself which is why she and Cameron
don't boast about their relationship
every chance they get since both actors
have a time-consuming profession they
tend to spend some months apart but hey
as long as they are both happy with
their arrangement we're delighted for
them watch until the end to find out how
the young couple fell in love with each
other
okay now that you've seen him go outside
and play save yourselves
part time lovers full time supporters
famous couples don't have a lot of time
on their hands for this reason many of
them choose to split up after growing
distance from one another
hopefully this won't be the case for
Peyton lists and Cameron Monaghan
now that the anthem of a teenage prophet
filming schedule is complete both Peyton
and camera are finding bigger fish to
fry Peyton is currently working on three
different productions all of which will
be released in 2018 so keep an eye out
for then came you valley girl and light
as a feather
if you think that Peyton has her hands
full wait until you hear what Cameron's
been working on this talented actor was
brought to stardom when he landed the
role of Ian Gallagher on the hit TV
series shameless however his diverse
acting talents weren't showcased until
he became the Joker on Gotham today
Cameron has three big projects in
pre-production so he's definitely
preparing for a whirlwind of action by
spending time with your significant
other is a must
actors like Peyton and Cameron don't
always have the time thankfully they
both have the same dream and encourage
each other to reach for the stars anthem
of a reluctant prophet some of the
greatest movies known to man are based
on books so why should anthem of a
teenage prophets be any different author
Joanna Prue is the genius behind the
plot and she's not one to mess around
originally the movie was going to be
named after the book however producers
soon changed the title from anthem of a
reluctant prophet to anthem of a teenage
prophet actress Peyton lists often slips
up and says the previous title
indicating that the altercation was a
last-second decision although the book
was published in 2007 it took over a
decade for it to get recognized as a
work of art and now it's about to come
to life on the big screen this
supernatural movie will shock and
excited sewers because let's face it
everyone likes to watch amazing artists
act out freaky scenarios when a 17 year
old named Luke unknowingly predicts his
best friend's death he's left to pick up
the pieces to make matters worse the
visions keep coming and he's falling in
love with someone he should be keeping
his distance from likes
that's a movie we can't wait to get our
hands on Payton played the younger
double for actresses like Kate Hudson
every person on this planet is unique in
their very own way but this doesn't mean
that they can't pose as other people
every once in a while it's common for
actors to need younger doubles when it
comes to flashback scenes so if you
happen to resemble other actors you
might just get cast based off your looks
since Payton began her acting career at
the age of four she was often used as an
extra in fact she played the younger
version of countless blonde actresses
Peyton was first used as a double in the
set of 27 dresses where she played the
younger version of Katherine Heigl's
character Jane a few years later Peyton
played the role of young Becky on the
sorcerer as a princess for actress
Teresa Palmer
lastly Peyton also doubled for the
renowned actress Kate Hudson in the
movie Something Borrowed
all in all posing as a young double
aloud Peyton to meet some of her heroes
growing up and it also motivated her to
learn roles outside of the Disney
Channel what do you want to be when you
got
she has an irrational fear fear is one
of the oldest emotions in the book which
is why everyone's experienced it at some
point in time whereas some people are
afraid of heights fight or flights
others have fears that aren't as common
although Peyton lists is a courageous
woman she does have an irrational fear
of her own and it's based on someone
else's experience when she was growing
up her uncle got trapped in a New York
subway carts for four hours unable to
wait any longer he pried open the subway
doors and followed the spooky tracks
back to safety this ordeal took place in
the dark which is something that always
stuck with Peyton so basically her
uncle's unfortunate encounter soon
became her biggest fear luckily her
Payton taking the subway isn't exactly
an everyday occurrence so she should be
safe from getting stuck underground in
the dark do you have any random fears of
your own if so spill the beans down in
the comment section who knows you might
find out that you're not the only one
how Payton and Cameron fell in love when
you think about it it isn't uncommon for
actors to fall for their on-screen
lovers as a matter of fact this is
something we've seen happen
time and time again back in 2017 actors
Peyton and Cameron were filming for the
movie anthem of a teenage prophet and it
didn't take long for them to develop
feelings for one another since the
project was on the low budget sigh the
cast was made to share a single trailer
which pushed the actors to get to know
each other on a personal level and
before long Peyton and Cameron were
making eyes at each other these talented
actors began falling for each other
midway through their filming schedule
and by the end of it they were an
official item although they're filming
schedules sometimes keep them apart the
lovebirds never fail to keep in touch
and visit each other when they have time
to spare knowing that their love is real
gives us that much more incentive to
watch anthem of a teenage prophet leave
a heart in the comments if you're a fan
of this adorable couple and that's it
for our video thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]